This is Jocko podcast number
23 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo, good evening.
Better
and faster and stronger
and smarter and wiser.
Always trying to get a little
bit of all those things
and we try and get wiser. That's
one of those things. That's wisdom,
which technically wisdom
comes from experience.
So how do you Garner experience you?
You can't just make yourself live
longer in a shorter period of time. No,
it doesn't work that way.
So what do we do to garner wisdom?
We look to the past.
You got to know your past,
you've got to know history.
And as I tell my son on
a pretty regular basis,
history revolves around war.
And in many ways history is war
and war.
Yeah,
is a human endeavor.
The worst of human endeavors.
Some.
But it is a human endeavor nonetheless.
And because it is a human endeavor,
it therefore reflects human nature.
And that's why we can learn so
much from the history of war,
not just about war itself,
but about man and about human nature.
And the same goes for principles of war.
The principles of war can be applied
to life, can be applied to business,
can be applied to relationships,
can be applied to every human endeavor.
And so with that in mind,
that full spectrum of application,
let's take a look at the oldest
book about the principles of war
written in 500 BC over 2,500 years ago.
A book whose principles still apply today,
some sues the art of War Sun Sue said
the art of war is a
importance to the state.
It is a matter of life and death.
A road either to safety or to ruin.
Hence it is a subject of inquiry
which can or no account be neglected.
You gotta study war
and like I said,
it is really about life in conflict
and friction in relationships and human
interaction. You're going to see all
of that when you start looking at the,
at the art of war
and he restarts talking about trying
to figure out who's going to win in a
situation
when seeking to determine the
military conditions. Let them be made.
The basis of,
of a comparison in this wise,
which of the two generals has most
ability on which side is discipline most
rigorously enforced?
Which army is stronger?
On which side?
Our officers and men most highly
trained in which army is there.
The greater constancy in
both reward and punishment.
Okay.
That's something you talked about Echo
Charles, and we're talking about kids.
You talked about how it's important
for the punishment to be constant and
consistent.
Yes.
Now what's interesting here, and this
is something we've talked about before,
and you know what?
I'm gonna say that a lot today.
This is something we've
talked about before because
when you start talking about
military strategy,
it runs through the ages.
There's threads that run through the
ages, and this is one of them. He says,
while heating the profit of my council,
avail yourself also have any helpful
circumstances over and beyond the ordinary
rules.
Okay?
According as circumstances are favorable,
one,
you should modify ones plans,
so don't get dead set on something.
Don't get locked into a plan.
You gotta be open to change it.
Yeah.
Continuing all warfare
is based on deception.
Hence,
when able to attack,
we must seem unable when using our forces.
We must seem inactive.
When we are near.
We must make the enemy believe
we are away when far away.
We must make him believe we are near
hold out baits to entice the enemy fame
disorder and crush him.
Now this is something that applies it
absolutely directly to Jujitsu. Obviously,
you know, uh Oh. Oh you, you think
you're going to get my arm? Boom.
I just, I just swept
you and got on top. Oh,
I'm really panicking. This situation.
Oh, guess what? I just got deep.
Half guard came out in the back and
now I'm going to choke you. Hmm.
Okay.
Back to the book. If he
is secured, all points,
be prepared for him if he is
superior and strength, evade him.
If your opponent is of Kolarik temper,
seek to irritate him.
Pretend to be weak,
that he may grow arrogant
so well. This is something people
don't think about. The fact that hey,
if your opponent has superior strength
of atum and obviously that's something
that we also heard from Mau,
the same,
that was the same gorilla strategy. If
your opponent strong, you avoid him,
and here he's saying if they've, if
they're losing their temper a little bit,
go ahead and irritate
them. Help that along. You
pretend to be weak so that your
opponent grows arrogant and thinks,
doesn't have to worry about you.
Hmm.
Continuing.
If he is taking his ease,
give him no rest. If his forces
are United, separate them.
Attack him where he's unprepared.
Appear where you are not expected.
These military devices leading to
victory must not be divulged beforehand.
It's,
it's,
it's strange that this is the oldest
book and this thread runs throughout
history and yet people
interacting with each other.
We'll constantly decide that
there's going to go toe to toe.
You're going to argue with me. Cool. I'm
just going to go toe to toe with you.
Yeah.
This is an intellectual approach
and I think that's, but you know,
if you're not detached,
it's harder to jump on that
intellectual methodology. Yes.
With you.
If you come at me with your argument
head on or you accuse me or you're trying
to tighten me up on something,
you're just being super direct with me.
It's your diet.
I might get offended and then what I'm
going to do when I go right back at you,
right? Instead of maneuvering
on you, right? So like, yeah,
if someone's super,
super smart or super calculated,
they're way more likely to
to sign on to this type of,
so as you started losing
your temper with someone,
think about what Echo Charles just said.
That means you're not being very smart
and you're not being very calculated
means you're making a mistake. You know
means there's a better route to go,
you know?
Okay,
now continuing.
Now the general who wins a battle makes
many calculations in his temple air.
The battle is fought.
The general who loses a battle makes
but few calculations beforehand.
So you got to plan and it's free.
It's interesting you the word calculate
calculative and he just used the same
word,
okay?
Now,
this is something that I've talked about
to fight and conquer and all your
battles is not supreme excellence.
Okay?
I'll say that again.
To fight and conquer in all your
battles is not supreme excellence.
Supreme Excellence consists in breaking
the enemy's resistance without fighting,
and I always take that one step further.
I always take the point that the enemy
doesn't even know that there was a fight,
right? Right. They didn't
even know what was happening.
They thought they were having dinner and
going to sleep, but they just got beat,
and that's especially true when you're in,
you're part of a team and
you're trying to win some.
Are you trying to push your idea through?
You're trying to,
trying to convince people of something.
The best way to convince them is when
you didn't go toe to toe with them.
They came to the conclusion themselves.
At least they think they did, right?
You fought them without fighting them.
Thus,
the highest form of general ship
is to block the enemy's plans.
The next best is to prevent
the junction of enemy forces.
The next in order is to
attack the enemy's army.
In the field and the worst policy
of all is to besieged walled cities.
The rule is not to besiege wall
cities if it can possibly be avoided.
Yeah.
Now,
this is another thing,
and I've said this on this podcast before,
which is if someone is super dug in on a
position or why are you going to attack
them?
If you have this belief that you're just
dug in on and I'm trying to maneuver
around it, why am I going to
attack that position? You've got,
you know more about it.
You've studied it.
You've been in this argument 47
times in the last three weeks,
so how am I going to come up against
you when you've got that well fortified
position? Yeah. The answer is I'm not.
It's not going to work out good for me.
Yeah.
Therefore, the skillful leader subdues
the enemy's troops without any fighting.
He captures their cities
without laying any siege.
He overthrows their kingdom without
lengthy operations in the field.
That's the goal. That
is the goal. You had.
Just something else about martial arts.
I think like when you get someone
that really knows how to fight,
most of the time you don't have to fight.
Yup. Most of the time you can tell,
people can tell that you know
how to fight. Like for instance,
when they get in your face and you smile
at them and you go, oh, let's do this.
Then they realize this is not a good idea.
Yeah.
Little projection of power
going on here.
Thus we may that there are five
essential oils for victory.
He will win. Who knows when to
fight and when not to fight.
This is sort of like when we were doing
Napoleon and and just about everything
in the book, you can just
stop and think about and it's,
and it's also sorta like Jujitsu
in that what you've learned,
it's once you hear it,
it seems super obvious,
but why aren't you thinking
about all the time? Right.
And why do you make stupid
mistakes that portray that rule?
Yeah. Cause it's not front
of your mind, right? Yeah.
It's like I said,
the two.
When you're emotionally charged,
it's you just handle things way different,
which it's kind of ironic in a way because
that's what makes this so effective
when people normally handle
themselves in that emotional way. Yes,
and that's what Vander
yourself in this way.
That's the very thing
that makes it effective.
Yeah.
The underlying theme to this,
the which hasn't been said,
I mean he doesn't address
this the way I addressed it,
the way I talk about it in our book,
the way we talked about
on the podcast is the,
the idea that you're talking about,
which is the idea of detaching and not
beat emotional so that you can do things
so that you can make good decisions.
Yeah.
Next he will win.
Who knows how to handle both
superior and inferior forces.
He will win whose army is animated by
the same spirit throughout all ranks.
Okay,
so if you're in a leadership position at,
you got part of your team on board
with the program, not good enough.
You've got to get the whole
team on board with the program.
That's who's going to win.
Okay.
He will win. Who prepared
himself, prepared himself,
waits to take the enemy unprepared.
I'm just going to wait until you're not
ready. Why would I square up? You know,
why would I do that? If you're ready
to fight me, I'm not going to go.
Let's just wait till
you're not expecting it.
Yeah.
Along with that emotional
kind of state that some
people are in where they,
where they don't exercise these types
of strategies along with the emotional
state is the ego to stickle state.
You know, the guy who was like, Hey,
I'm just going to stand toe to toe. And
you're like, all right. That's tough.
That's, that's, you know, that might,
it might make for a show in a
fighting MMA situation in it.
But as far as the strategy to win,
that's again,
it's cool for the show. But as far
as winning, actually winning, um,
it might not be the best. We'll just
say that. Yeah, I would agree with you.
Yeah.
Number five,
he will win.
Who has military capacity and is not
interfered with by the sovereign.
Okay.
Victory lies in the, of those
five points. So that means you,
you can't get micromanaged.
If you're being micromanaged
by the, by higher powers,
you're going to have problems.
And here's the classic classic
saying that everyone's heard.
Hence the saying,
if you know the enemy and know yourself,
you need not fear the
result of a hundred battles.
If you know yourself, but not the
enemy, for every victory gained,
you will off also suffer a defeat.
If you know neither
the enemy nor yourself,
you will succumb in every battle.
So you got to know yourself and that's
the one that you know, that's, that's you,
that's your team. That's you.
That's why you got to learn.
That's why you've got to study.
That's why you got to train.
That's why you got to test yourself too.
It's why you got to put pressure on
yourself because you don't know yourself
unless you put yourself into
those situations. Yup. Physically,
mentally stress.
That's what you want to go into
so that you know yourself. Yeah.
When we used to send CEO Paul,
when we sent the opportunities over seas,
they know what their limitations are.
They been tested hard
individually and as a unit. Yeah.
Going on son Sue said, and this is
actually that's a quote from the book,
so I guess he must've wrote that
because this is a allegedly a literal
translation of the of of Sun Tzu and so
he starts off his statements with Sun.
Sue said
the good fighters of old put first put
themselves beyond the possibility of
defeat and then waited for an opportunity
of defeating the enemy to secure
ourselves against a feat
lies in our own hands,
but the opportunity of defeating the
enemy is provided by the enemy himself.
So he's going to talk about that more
and it is laced throughout this book that
you got to focus on your game.
You got to focus on your what you can do
in the situation now worried about them
but like what can I do to be prepared,
put myself beyond the
possibility of defeat.
Hence the skillful fighter puts himself
into a position which makes defeat
impossible and does not miss the moment
for defeating the enemy going on,
son Sue said
the control of a large force is the same
in principle as the control of a few
men. It is merely a question
of dividing up their numbers.
Now when I wrote about that and Lafe
and I talk about that all the time,
that's decentralized command,
dividing up the numbers and
having subordinate leadership,
running the teams and having sub more
did leadership inside teams running
smaller teams.
That's all it is.
The principle of control is the same.
Now we get into a little bit of
direct versus indirect. Again,
a topic that I talk about all the time
in all fighting the direct method
bay may be used for joining battle,
but indirect methods will be
needed in order to secure victory.
Indirect tactics efficiently applied
are inexhaustible as heaven and earth on
ending as the flow of rivers and
streams like the sun and moon.
They end,
but to begin a new like the four seasons
they pass but to return once more.
So he's talking about how when you
get to indirect hacks, there's there,
there are infinite numbers, infinite
numbers of ways to approach things.
There are not more than five musical
notes yet. The combination of these. Note,
these five give rise to more
melodies than can ever be heard.
There are not more than five
primary colors yet in combination.
They produce more huge
than can ever be seen.
There are not more than five cardinal
tastes yet combinations of them yield
flavors,
more flavors than can
ever be tasted in battle.
There are not more than
two methods of attack.
The direct and indirect,
yet these two in combination give rise
to an endless series of maneuvers.
The direct and indirect lead
on to each other intern.
It is like a moving circle.
You never come to an end who can exhaust
the possibilities of their combination.
Yeah,
he went a little,
he would descriptive right there.
He was obviously convinced as I am to
that even though there's basic maneuvers,
the the way that you
apply them is limitless
and that's one of the things
that makes leadership hard.
Cause when you're dealing with
people, I mean there's, there's,
there's a certain number of types of
personalities you got to deal with,
but then those personalities are all
mixed together in a way that you have to
react to them and treat
them a certain way and
how the two are the same and then you
have to deal with how they interact with
each other as well.
And then not to mention the fact that
they may or may not change as individual
as the day goes on. As the day
goes on, they start getting hungry,
they start getting
angry. Yeah, right. Well,
well maybe they just watched a romantic
comedy and they're feeling a little
different. Let's hope that's
not the case or whatever.
I Dunno why I think romantic.
All right.
Back to Sun Su Sun sue said,
whoever is in the first,
in the field and awaits the coming of
the enemy will be fresh for the fight.
Whoever second in
the field and has to hasten to
the battle will arrive exhausted.
Therefore, the clever combatant
imposes his will on the enemy,
but does not allow the enemy's
will to be imposed on him.
Hear that all the time in MMA. Who's
going to impose their will on this fight?
Hmm.
By holding out advantages to him,
he can cause the enemy to approach of
his own accord. That's Bait, right?
Or by inflicting damage, he can make it
impossible for the enemy to draw near.
If the enemy is taking his ease,
meaning if the enemy's trying to rest,
he can harass him. If well
supplied, he can starve them out.
If quietly and camped,
he can force him to move.
So all these are just little things
to basically annoy the enemy, right?
Throw him off his game,
throw him off of his game.
Appear at points which the enemy must
hasten to defend march swiftly to places
where you are not expected.
Okay.
And Army May march great
distances without distress.
If he marches through country
where the enemy is not,
you can be sure of it's of
succeeding in your attacks.
If you attack places
which are not defended,
totally obvious, right? You can
be sure of succeeding in your tax.
If you attack places
which are not defended.
And this is something that
we do in Jujitsu, you know,
you're attacking the NAC,
they're protecting the neck
there. Protect the neck,
boom arm or you're going for Camille,
you're going to freaking mirror,
you're going for Canberra. Boom. Straight
arm mock other arm. Yeah. Big One is you,
when you fake a submission to go
for a guard pass or something,
that's not a submission, you know?
Yeah. Cause it, it throws your mind off.
Like Greg does it really well where he'll
go for that guillotine and you're like,
oh he's going for a submission. So your
mind, it's one thing to be like, okay,
I see he's going from my neck and
then get my arm could be exposed.
It's, that's one thing
because you're thinking, okay,
this submission to this next
submission, but if it's, you know,
if they're going for something
completely different,
different aspect of the game,
it throws you off even more.
He's got me with that like three
times in a row before. Yeah.
That's basically going to even further
to the flank. Yeah. Yang, some, you know,
you're expecting this,
somebody to shoot you with a machine gun.
They start lobbing mortars at you.
Yeah. You weren't ready for that at all.
Or they start like taking
your guys' hostage it in the,
went back through the back door
or something like that. You know?
Completely different.
Yeah.
You can ensure the safety of your defense
if you hold only positions that cannot
be attacked. How obvious is that? Yeah.
Let's just get in positions where we
can't be attacked and then we will defend
them very easily.
Okay.
The spot where we intend to
fight must not be made known for.
Then the enemy will have to prepare
against a possible attack at several
different points,
and his forces being thus
distributed in many directions.
The numbers we shall have to face at
any given point will be proportionately,
phew.
So you don't want to let the enemy know
where you're gonna attack him because
then he can defend that specific area.
Whereas if he has to
defend all of his areas,
he's got less people defending
where you're going to attack.
We did that really well in World
War II, the d day, you know they,
the Germans did not know. They were
suspect where we were going to attack,
but they didn't know it was Normandy,
so they had a lot of defenses strewed
about and other areas and costume.
Okay.
Now here we go with how we
deal with what the enemy does.
Four should the enemy's
strength in his van,
which van is like the division at the
front. It's the front of your troops van.
That's why they like the term fan.
Guard is like your front front guard.
Four should the enemy strengthen his van?
He will weakened his rear
should he strengthened his rear,
he will weaken his van. Should
he strengthened his left?
He will. Weaken is right.
Should he strengthened his right?
He will weakened his left.
If he sends reinforcements everywhere,
he will be everywhere week
and that's what you know. Again,
going into Jujitsu when someone is,
when you feel in passing and they're
locking you and they're thinking about a
knee lock and [inaudible],
they got all those things going on at
the same time and you're just trying to
spread your defenses then then when they
do one of those three you're in trouble
and I always explained to people,
you know when you, it's easy,
it's pretty easy for anybody.
If you tell me how I'm going to try and
straighten out your arm and that's my
whole focus is to stop you for straighten
my arm. It's you know, I can do it.
I can do it pretty well.
I'm well defended on that area.
There is no opening somewhere else. Right
and the same thing with guard passing.
If I'm trying to pass
your guard all tight,
low and heavy and you're just
defending, defending, defending,
that means there's an opening somewhere
else probably far away from you. Yeah,
super common one with guard passing
is you know, you smashed to the,
you know one side, right? You're smashing,
smashing to one site and then you hop
your hip though to the other site wide
open all the time.
And the harder you smashed,
the more wide open that far side is. Yeah,
that's a common one. Yeah. It's just a,
it's just a distraction.
And then a flank,
son Sue's been doing it for 2,500 years.
Ang.
All right. Do not repeat the
tactics would you have gained?
Okay,
you're on victory. Do not repeat the
tactics which have gained you won victory,
but let your methods be regulated by
the infinite variety of circumstances.
Okay.
Military tactics are like unto water for
water in its natural course runs away
from high places and hastens downward.
So in war,
the way to avoid what is strong
is to strike what is weak.
Now, this is something that we
definitely got raised within seal teams.
You don't use the same methodology over
and over and over again and development
pattern. You don't do it no matter
how minor you change things up,
you change things up. And that's something
that any good military unit does.
It's something that any, anybody
that's uh, being, uh, threatened.
You know, if your life is in danger,
you don't set a pattern on what you do,
you change it up.
Hmm.
Water shapes its course according
to the ground over which it flows.
The soldier works out his victory in
relation to the Foa whom he is facing,
therefore,
just as water retains no constant shape.
So when warfare,
there are no constant conditions.
You got to have an open mind.
You can't get trapped
inside your own tactics.
inside your own game.
And I see this with businesses we work
with, with companies that we work with,
where they have got their thing that
they've done and they've been successful
for six years running,
and then all of a sudden something
changes and they're trying to run the same
methodology without ever stepping back
and saying, wait a second. We did well.
We had a 12% growth average
for the past six years,
and all of a sudden we're
down 22%. What happened? Well,
let's just do what we did before again
and again. That's what, that's what,
how people spiral into a bankruptcy.
Why?
Because the conditions change,
the conditions change field and they
don't look and say, oh, the enemy adapted,
the competitor's adapted.
You know,
we can look at some of these
businesses that have gone on. I mean,
the music industry has
changed dramatically. No cds.
I mean, imagine if you owned a CD
production warehouse somewhere. I mean,
you wouldn't [inaudible] cds. Yeah.
Tower records. Classic example. Yeah.
Yeah. And, and back to the
[inaudible] doing the same
thing over and over again. Like, you know,
if you succeed with this one, you know,
method, it's like salespeople,
salespeople, they really
low. A lot of them,
they really look at sales as
this kind of war. You know,
it's me get someone makes the sale.
Either you sell them your product or they
sell you why they can't buy whatever.
Um, when you see as a
consumer, when you see the low,
especially from sales people directly,
when you see the same
language over and over, after a while you
like, I see exactly what you're doing.
I see what you're doing.
You know how they ask you.
They'll ask you a question that if you
say no to you look dumb or something like
that. Yeah. So I dunno if they say
yes 15 times in a row and then yeah,
they'd be like, oh obviously
right. And you're like, I can't,
you kind of feel like you can't say no,
but after a while you're like,
I see what you're doing.
You know, so let me work.
Cause then they probably teach them
that, you know? So if it's like, oh yeah,
that works. That's,
that works. That works.
But yeah, it was starting to get hip
to it. Stuff won't work anymore. Not,
it's definitely not gonna work on
that cove, Charles. No, no, no.
I see what you're doing. I see
what you guys are doing. All right.
And this is just restating the same thing.
He who can modify his tactics in relation
to his opponent and thereby succeed in
winning may be called
a heaven born captain.
So if you can look at what your opponent's
doing, and this is something that,
again, I see companies do it.
I see Jujitsu players do it.
They have that one thing that they're
used to and then someone's really good at
defending that one thing and they just
keep going against to keep going against,
to keep going against it and keep
running into that brick wall and it's not
going to get you where you want
to be. Yeah, it's problematic.
Here we go from Sun Su, a soldier
spirit, his keenest in the morning.
By noon day it has begun to flag and
in the evening his mind is bent only on
returning to camp.
A clever,
a clever general therefore avoids an
army when it's spirit is keen but attacks
when is sluggish and in
Thai inclined to return.
This is the art of studying moods.
I liked that. The Art of studying
moods. This is about knowing people.
Yeah.
That kind of like the guy in Jujitsu
class who shows up 15 minutes before the
class ends when everyone's
been rolling. Yeah. Yeah.
He's getting everyone on
there and sluggish, threatened
to go back to camp like,
hey guys,
want to roll off fresh?
Yeah.
It is a military axiom not to advance
uphill against the enemy nor to oppose him
when he comes downhill.
Do not pursue an enemy
who simulates flight.
Do not attack soldiers
whose temper is keen.
Do not swallow a bait
offered by the enemy.
Do not interfere with an army
that's returning home as a good one.
They're going, they're running.
Let them run. Let them go home.
They're going to fight hard to get home,
right?
They got visions of their
family and their head.
When you surround an army,
leave an outlet free.
Do not press a desperate photo too hard,
and this is something you
see psychologically a lot.
You know with an argument,
you got a couple of executives and maybe
the senior executive has a plan and no
one likes the plan.
Well,
you just don't want to box him in and
prove them wrong in front of everybody,
right? You don't want to do
that. You want to be crafty.
We want to get yourself sued together.
You want to leave them a little opening
where he can say, you know what?
After reconsidering,
I've decided I want to go with this
other way because figured out that
blah, blah, blah. I
give them an out. Yeah.
What you don't want to do is make him
stick to this bad plan because his ego is
making them stick there.
Yeah.
Recognize,
okay.
Do not linger in dangerously
isolated positions
when you're doing Jujitsu.
Don't,
when someone gets across side,
you scramble, you go crazy.
Don't let him settle there.
When somebody is trying to get that
Kogi color up underneath your head and
they're going to have you trapped.
Don't let them get there. Don't,
don't linger in dangerously
isolated positions. Move. Yeah.
Yeah. It's W it's, it gets so complex
with this and in Jujitsu worked.
So just get considered what, just what
you said, because this is kind of,
it kind of overflows into the another
part that you just talked about.
So let's say the example of the guy
passing your guard into your site control.
Right. During his pass you said
don't let him settle. Exactly. So,
but when he, let's say whatever, you
lose the fight for whatever reason,
any does settle.
Now you're faced with a situation
where if he settled on you hard,
where he's,
you can tell he's putting strength into
holding that position and you then you
try to scramble, you're going against,
you're going full speed, you know,
toe to toe like Oh, he said not to do. So
at that point you got a change strategy.
If you had, had already lost that battle,
you and he settled and he's putting his,
his energy into holding you,
now you got to play another
tactic that he said, let him,
you know, you got to relax a little bit.
And so he starts relaxing a little bit.
You know what I mean? It's like that's
a common thing that's like, you know,
a pretty well known strategy,
I would say. When you,
when you get advanced and you do too,
but it's crazy how he just lays it out.
And that's the perfect
exact exact example. Yeah.
All in one little one little move,
one little movement.
And actually he continues on that.
Same,
on that same thread in
hemmed in situations.
In other words, when you're surrounded
in your, you're under the bad situation,
you must resort to stratagem and
stratagem doesn't really mean strategy.
It means like tricks or deceptions.
So you've,
you've given up, you've, you've,
you've given up your position.
The person is dominating you now and
exactly what you're saying is correct.
When someone has got you in that position,
either in an argument or a plan or a
situation that you're in a relationship,
they've got you locked down,
stop fighting. Yup. You,
it's not going to work. You're, they've
got you. If you continue to struggle,
you just going to wear yourself out.
You're going to worsen the scenario
stop and now you have to start thinking
about a trick to get out of there.
So I'm kind of a better tactic,
some kind of a deception,
something to get you out of there because
going strength to strength isn't going
to do it. They're in a superior position.
You know,
sometimes you can tell someone's doing
that if you have them in a situation and
they start actually using this tactic.
Little strict, a little tricks.
One that I've been able to recognize
is they do like some ad Hominem fucking
argument. They'll start
attacking something else. Yeah,
yeah, of course. But it's a,
yeah. If you, if you kind of have
a handle on the whole situation,
it's real obvious. Yeah.
Yeah. And then he says,
in a desperate position,
you must fight.
Now the difference here is now there's a
submission. Hold on you. Yeah. No choice.
You have to fight. You're going to
fight fighter. You're gonna tap. Yeah.
So you get that situation where it's gone
beyond just their secure and they've,
they've got you in a dominant position,
but now they're actually
going to kill you. Right.
You have no choice but to buy
the last level of settling.
Now this is interesting.
There are roads which must
not be followed. Armies,
which must not be attacked. Towns
which must not be besieged positions,
which must not be contested
commands of the sovereign,
which must not be obeyed.
Hmm.
So it's always interesting to me when
you hear somebody that's a military
mastermind and they're saying that there
are orders from their sovereign that
must not be obeyed.
Hmm.
And I think we've heard that,
and this is something that people aren't
familiar with the military or aren't
familiar with military history. They think
everyone just follows. Orders, follows,
orders, follows orders. But
Napoleon we've heard say it,
Sun who we've heard say it.
We've heard these repeated things
where people say, you know what,
that's the wrong order and
I'm not going to do it.
Hmm.
And it's interesting too,
the other dichotomy has all these people
talk about the necessity of discipline
and inherit and discipline is
absolutely the following of orders.
But as much of as stringent as I
am about discipline, hmm. If I'm,
I want my guys to question my worst, I
want them to say, Hey, wait a second.
Why is Jocko making us do
this? He's, he's wrong.
I don't want them just obeying me blindly.
Hmm.
Is You don't want your team obeying
you blindly. You don't want that.
You want them to be
thinking back to the book.
The Art of war teaches us to rely not
on the likelihood of the enemy's not
coming,
but on our own readiness to receive him.
Not on the chance of his not attacking,
but rather on the fact that we have
made our position on the salient ball.
So what that is,
again,
he's putting the the preponderance of
the outcome, not on what the enemy does,
but on what you do.
Hmm.
It's not what happens is not
what happens to in your life.
It's what you do.
It's what's you prepare for.
It's your own readiness that's
going to affect the outcome,
not the chance of what
the enemy's done done.
It's how have you made your position?
How have you set yourself up? How have
you prepared? How have you trained?
How have you worked?
That's where the outcome comes from.
Not what the world does to you,
but what you do to the world.
There are five dangerous faults which
may affect a general one recklessness,
which leads to the
destruction to cowardice,
which leads to capture.
So those two,
you got one guy that's a
maniac that doesn't care.
He's going to go get after it.
He's going to die.
You've got someone else that's a coward.
He's going to get captured.
Three,
a hasty temper that can
be provoked by insults.
Dangerous,
a delicacy of honor that
is sensitive to shame.
Sort of the same thing.
And then over solicitude for his men,
which exposes him to worry and
trouble and oversell a stew.
That's basically you over affectionate.
You care about the men so much
that exposes you to worry and trouble.
These are the five per setting sins
of a general ruinous to the conquer,
ruinous to the conduct of war.
Some things to watch out for
it. It's interesting, you know,
obviously the one that's,
that's
I guess the most controversial to me
is that over solicitude for his men,
which exposes him to worry
in trouble because you know,
in the modern military, you know,
he was dealing with conscripts.
So even eat, it's interesting, even
conscripts back then he's saying, hey,
you could get too affectionate
with your conscripts
and now we have brothers
and so you're gonna,
you're gonna care about your guys,
you're going to care about your guys
more than anything else in the world.
But what you have to counter
that with is not, hey,
I'm not going to care
about them. No, it's,
I'm going to make sure I do everything I
can to keep them safe. Yeah. Yeah. I think
like,
you know how in,
in a lot of companies they discourage
fraternizing with your coworkers.
So I used to work in the nightclub
industry where, you know,
from time to time people would
hookup.
So what that can can
result in is, um, you know,
people who are too focused on the
relationship between each versus
their job go or, yeah. So
there's a total assumption,
but maybe that's what he's talking
about exactly what he's talking about.
That's exactly what he's talking about.
And,
but if you take that into
the military scenario, it's,
you know,
like I said,
you're going to care about your guys so
much and you have to counter that with
the fact that you have
a duty and you have,
you have a job and that
everybody on your team,
like we were in the seal teams,
you all know the risk. Yeah. Yeah.
Everybody knows the risk. Everybody
knows that when you go on an operation,
it might be your last operation. You
get hit with an ID, you get shot,
you get mortared, you
get blown up. I mean,
everybody accepts that risk
and that therefore as a leader,
you know you're not imposing
that risk upon them.
They volunteered for that risk and I
think that's what allows a modern military
commander to to say,
Hey, I love these guys,
but they all know what they signed up for.
There's going to be risk here and
we've got a job to do as opposed to,
Hey,
I love these guys.
They don't want to be here and I'm
going to send them to their deaths.
That would not,
that would be a different scenario or
harder scenario or you got clothes.
Let's say you know you're, you're
in command of you know, 10 guys,
five of those guys are your best friends
and you get too attached in the sense
that you have a mission that you have to
do a dangerous one, but you're like, Hey,
I'm not going to send those five guys
because they're going to be at risk.
I want to keep them safe, you know,
so I don't want to send them there.
The other five guys go rather than the
10. And you know, messes up your whole,
your whole job. Which oddly enough,
I always sent like the guys,
I love it. Worst
scenario, all my brothers,
they would be lining up and
saying, I'm going, I'm going.
I was fired up. Siva. Yeah.
I mean,
you're obviously
very specific type of person and you guys
probably are too, I would imagine. Um,
but still it, you're still
exercising that discipline between,
you know, them potentially going to their
death and that job you guys have to do.
So you're, you're thinking of it in a
smarter way. Know what's interesting,
I just thought of this like if a guy
got in trouble for whatever reason,
when we were over on deployment,
whenever I was on deployment combat,
if a guy got in trouble,
you know what their punishment would be.
You're not allowed to go on a mission.
I know.
So just so that just tells you what
kind of an attitude. Yeah. You know,
the guys that we're working
with, it's like, oh,
you can't go on these next three missions.
Yeah,
guys are angry because they realize
they're letting their buddies down and if
something goes wrong and they're not
there, it's a nightmare. Yeah. And their,
their, their duty, their job is,
is it's part of them. You know,
where I was listening to this thing
where he's talking about this,
the Amish Amish people. Right. And
they're really into work, you know,
hard work and stuff. So one of the
punishments for the kids would be,
you're not allowed work.
Yeah. It's the same.
It's like saying it's like there.
Yeah. Same thing. Yeah. Meanwhile,
my kids, I got a beat them senseless
to get them to do any work.
Just kidding.
But I guarantee they're not working as
hard as some Amish kid out in the field.
Yeah. Putting up buildings with the
wood nails that they do. I mean, yeah.
It's awesome. Yeah. The work is obviously
part of their identity, you know, so like,
you know,
it's certain things people,
let's say quote unquote
normal people might find like,
like exercise for example.
Like if, so if let's say you're just an
average person who's like, man, I got to,
I'm going to make a new year's resolution.
I'm going to lose some weight or whatever,
I'm going to get a trainer.
It's hard for them. It's worked for them.
Right? So if the trainers like, Hey,
today's rest day, and they'd be like, oh,
sweet. You know, but then you take you,
for example, like how you were
saying your wife is like, hey,
maybe don't go to Jujitsu today.
You're all pissed. Yeah. You know?
So it's the exact opposite. But, so
that's kind of the, the scenario when it,
when it's ingrained in you and the,
and it starts to become part of your
identity work or not work. You want to,
you want to get that done.
Yeah.
That's interesting how those,
those embedded feelings,
yeah. Developing your life.
But what an awesome deal.
Like, if you think about
that, we would actually,
if we had to punish our guys would
punish them by saying you can't go on to
missions. Perfect. It'd be angry.
Maybe both. It, it'd be let down.
They'd like help everyone get ready
and they'd stand there whenever it was
leaving and learn their lesson
for sure. Heard him. Hold on.
All right,
next when the enemy is close
at hand and remains quiet,
he is relying on the natural
strength of his position.
This is a good one. So when you,
when you're, when you're in Jujitsu,
when someone for instance pulls
guard real quick, you know,
they've got a good guard. You know,
when someone's like all standing up and,
and all upright and reaching for your
color while you're standing, you know,
they got some judo going on.
So it's funny how when when
people have a dominant position,
they'll lean towards it.
Yeah.
If his place of encampment
is easy of access,
he is tendering a bait. Hmm. So if it
looks, if it looks too good to be true,
it's too good to be true.
You've got to watch that
when there is much running about,
it means that the critical moment has come
when some are advancing and
some retreating. It is a lure.
When soldiers stand
leaning on their spears,
they are faint from want to food.
If those who are sent to draw
water begin by drinking themselves.
The army is suffering from thirst.
If the enemy sees an advantage to
be gained and makes no effort to it,
the soldiers are exhausted.
If birds gather on any spot,
it is unoccupied.
If there is disturbance in the camp,
the general's authority is weak.
If the banners and flags are
shifted about sedition is afoot.
Yeah.
When an army feeds it's horses with
grain and kills it's cattle for food and
when the men do not hang their cooking
pots over the campfires showing that they
will not return to their tents,
you may know that they are
determined to fight to the death.
The sight of men whispering together
in small knots and speaking and subdued
tones points to dissatisfaction
amongst the rank and file.
Okay,
now the all those right there.
What I really like about those because
some of them are obviously are a little
bit archaic, you know, people
leaning on their spears, people, uh,
not putting out there cooking pots.
Those aren't things that
we're going to see today.
But what's so key about this is how
observing how people act can tell you much
more if you're paying attention
to it. Yeah. You know,
you see people talking amongst
themselves and small group,
there's a problem going
on. Yup. You know, the,
those are the kinds of things
that you gotta be aware of as a,
especially as a leader when you're
in a leadership position and you,
you see and you look and you
watch and you've listened.
Cause I see some people, some leaders,
they get isolated from the troops.
They get isolated from the situation,
they get isolated from the enemy.
They're not reading what's happening.
Mm.
So you've got to have this
awareness and the sensitivity,
right. It's a sensitivity. It's a sixth
sense of, hey, something's not right here.
And what are you picking that up from?
Yeah.
You know when you walk in a room,
everyone's all talking or you see it
from a distance people were talking and
then when you either walk by or
you joined them, they are there.
They happen to be done
talking every single time.
That's not going to be a good side.
They're talking
back to the book.
He,
you exercises no forethought but makes
light of his opponents is sure to be
captured by them.
Okay?
So when you're saying all,
we'd have nothing to fear
here, we can take these guys,
we can win that contract. We can
beat the opponent, we can win.
That's when you're going to be taken down.
If soldiers are punished before
they have grown attached to you,
they will not prove submissive.
And unless submissive,
they will be practically useless.
If when the soldiers have become attached
to you, punishments are not enforced,
they will still be useless.
Therefore,
soldiers must be treated in the
first instance with humanity,
but kept under control by
means of iron discipline.
This is a certain road to victory.
If in training soldiers commands
are habitually enforced,
the army will be well disciplined.
So now you do realize that Sun Su 2,500
years ago was leading humans and if you
came out of the gate before they
knew you and you treated them bad,
they were never going to work for you.
They will never going to
submit to what you want to do.
Hmm.
And once they were attached to you,
if you had punishments and now you had
built enough respect and then you said
you were going to punish them
for something that they did you,
you set a certain standard
and then you don't hold it,
they're going to be equally useless.
Yup. Inconsistent inconsistency.
I firmly believe in if,
if in training soldiers commands
are habitually in forced,
the army will be well disciplined.
You got to stay consistent and you got
to remember that you're dealing with
humans.
Yeah.
When common soldiers are too strong
and their officers are too weak,
the result is insubordination.
And this is something that I saw a couple
of times in my career where I had a
guy that worked for me
who was a tough guy.
This happened a couple times, just
a bad ass guys. Super tough beast,
hardcore go getter. And
when they work for me, man,
I loved him and they did anything.
I would tell him to go, you know,
run through a brick wall.
They would start running and they
would run through the brick wall.
They'd figured out they'd get
through that thing super hard.
Okay.
And then, uh, one guy I like,
I went to another team and he went on
another deployment and got sent home from
deployment because he was just too much
to handle. And his support, he didn't,
I talked to him about he goes off,
my officers were weak.
He literally said my officers
were week. Okay. And so here is,
is like a caged animal that if you don't,
if he doesn't know who, but who are the
bosses and he doesn't respect the boss,
he's not gonna listen you, he was
the Alpha male. Yeah. Right. Yeah.
And when he was the Alpha Male,
he was doing whatever you want.
It wasn't listening to these people
that were in charge of him. Hmm. Yeah.
What is that like a like a mix of
like he doesn't,
I don't know if they look up to him,
but there's a sense of that right?
Where a if,
if your leader is,
it's just respect you had that kind of
ingrained respect and then not to mention
on top of that you don't fear any real
consequences from him. Cause thing,
you know, it's kind of weak. I can take
whatever you can dish out kind of thing.
So it's both of those you think? Yeah.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. This one guy that,
that this happened with,
I taught him Jujitsu and he was excited
about it in a way that I've never seen
anyone excited,
like super happy about knowing
that you could choke people and,
and he would get into fights in the
civilian world and come and give me these
full debriefs and ask me for
like pointers and judgment.
And that was,
you know,
a warrior that like to fight.
Yeah.
He found out that you could grab
people and then submit them.
He was super excited about it.
Like a little kid.
And I always say that that's kind of the,
the risk you run with teaching people
Jujitsu cause it is like I'm going to,
it's a super power essentially because
you don't have to learn that much for it
to be effective in this huge way.
So you know like kind of like
superman with great power comes great
responsibility. Yeah. Yeah.
It goes on to say when the officers are
too strong and the common soldiers two
weeks,
the result is collapse.
So when you put the super hardcore
guy over that can't modulate his,
his leadership,
he can't back off and build people
up before he starts to smash him.
You're going to get claps and that's
something you definitely got to look out
for it.
If you,
especially if you're a super strong
leader and you come and take over a team
that's been led by somebody that's weak,
there's a chance that the players and
the team are weak and now you've got to
come in and you got to build them
up before you let loose your vicious
leadership power.
Right?
You can't just come in there with the
Iron Fist and start dropping hammers. No.
You need to say, hey guys, all right,
let's go. Let's build this team up.
Then you can,
you can escalate your own force as your
subordinates grow and become powerful
themselves, but you don't want there
to be a huge gap between your power.
Yeah, and theirs because they
won't, they won't develop into it.
They'll just be in the shadow.
They won't grow in the shadow.
You got to come down and let some light
get to them and let them grow. Right
when the general was
weekend without authority,
when his orders are
not clear and distinct,
when there are no fixed duties assigned
to officers and men and the ranks are
formed in a Slava and
Lee haphazard manner,
the result is other disorganization.
Okay,
pretty clear.
If fighting is sure to result in victory,
then you must fight.
Even though the ruler forbid it.
If fighting will not result in victory,
then you must not fight
even at the rulers bidding.
Once again,
disobeying the chain of command.
Sun Sue himself disobeying
the chain of command.
Okay.
This is a big one.
The general who advances without coveting
fame had retreats without fearing
who's only thought is to protect his
country and do good service for his
sovereign is the jewel of the kingdom.
So that guy that's not
doing this to get famous,
that's not doing this for awards.
It's not doing this to get promoted.
It's not being brave to be promoted.
He's doing this to protect the country
or to carry out the mission, not
doing it for glory. And furthermore,
the same person can retreat
without feeling Micah disgraced.
That means they're gonna protect their
people without going all. We can't.
We can't fall back.
This person is the jewel of the kingdom,
the jewel of the kingdom, and it's
beautiful. Your work for people like that.
You know that what they're trying to
do, what they're trying to do, good.
They're trying to do their mission.
They're trying to do good for the country
that tried to do good for the team.
They're trying to do good for the
business. That's what we're trying to do.
They're not trying to get promoted.
They're not trying to get an award.
They're not trying to get a good
fitness report or a good evaluation.
They're trying to do a good job.
And that's why when people ask me a lot,
you know, all, I've got this boss that
wants to get the credit for everything,
give it to them.
Yeah. Give it to them. Let them look good.
Don't do it for, don't do it for
your glory. Give that glory away.
It feels good to give glory way.
Give it away.
I told you he used to work
in the nightclub right back
when I was young and kind
of the protocol would
be to, you know, we'd,
we'd work or whatever and the bartenders
would give us tips on like a little
sound clips, right? So at the end of
the week you'd be kind of pooled, right.
And we'd get some tips at the end of
the week. That's cool. Whatever. And um,
so my boss, so it was back when I first
started, my bought the head door guy,
right?
He was at the end of the week,
he called his own little meeting
with us and we're like, all right.
So he kind of goes over some stuff.
I don't even know what it was and um,
and he busted at the end.
He's like, Oh hey guys. Uh,
so yeah, we have tips. So
what I did was, you know, hey,
you guys are doing a great
job. So what I did was I, I,
I took my tips and I gave it to you
guys and he kind of had this look on his
face looking at us as if he needed us
to be like, wow, that was so great.
But you know, when the look is
so transparent, he's like, so
I was like this guy, it's like so
disingenuous. You know? Like he,
he wanted the credit and he wanted to
speak like, aw, thank you. Thank you.
You know, it wasn't that much by the way.
This is, you know, it's $14 each if that.
Cause we got to divide it up anyway.
But yeah,
that was like is the clear example of
that very thing right there where he's
given us the tips. I know
what he did that, yeah. Okay.
You lost 14,
my youngest daughter,
she does good deeds for the
sole purpose of increasing
birthday present Christmas present.
Does it that kind of go into a different
strategy altogether though? You know,
it's pretty, it's pretty cute. And
you see this six year old like Daddy,
I decided it would be really great if I
picked up your socks. Right. Wait, they,
since my birthday is coming.
Right. But that's a, that's
another tactic. It's like,
it's called for a super cool something
like when you do something and then, yeah,
yeah, yeah. But what that it's
effective. W uh, uh, heart
accretion is used to do it.
They'd be like, you know
what? Hey, hey, um, you know
what? Whatever their messages.
And they'd be like, Hey, take this free
gift. And they give you like, I dunno,
a flower or a book or something and
they know that that will leave you,
that the typical person, they'd leave them
with a feeling of Dang. Like I kind of,
Oh, this person, he, he was so nice to
me. I can't just walk off and be a Dick,
you know, so I'll give you
five bucks or dollar. Yeah.
Especially when you
recognize they're doing it.
In fact that you do yourself a disservice
to fall for it because they're going
to keep doing it. You know? It's basically
guilting someone in to do something,
but it's called a reciprocal
recipe. I don't know. Something
reciprocal, something.
Well, I guess we'll look that up
and figure it out later. Otherwise,
what's called reciprocal something.
Yeah.
All right. Now, here we go. This is
speaking to kids. This is awesome.
Regard your soldiers as your children
and they will follow you into the deepest
valleys.
Look on them as your own beloved sons
and they will stand by you even unto
death.
Completely true statement,
completely true statement.
If however,
you are indulgent,
been unable to make your
authority felt kind hearted,
but unable to enforce your commands and
incapable moreover of quelling disorder,
then your soldiers must be
likened to spoil children.
They are useless for
any practical purpose.
I think that speaks for itself.
If you are so lenient with your troops,
when they say indulgent, that's what I
mean to me to like super lenient. Yeah.
When you're lenient with your troops,
when you can't make your authority felt,
when you're super kind hearted,
you're unable to enforce your commands,
all those things are gonna end up with
a spoiled little kids for troopers and
they're not gonna, they're
gonna be worthless. I got
a little saying about kids,
lay it on me. If you had, if you're
helping them, you're hurting them.
Think about it. If you're helping
them, you're hurting them. Yeah.
You want me to tie your shoe,
tie yourself because what?
That when they tie their
shoes that literally, uh,
trains their fine motor skills.
If you want them, you know,
if they want a glass of water,
go get your own glass of water.
Right?
They want help moving
something across the hallway.
You move it across the hallway.
If you're helping your kids,
you're hurting your kids. Right. And I
could take it one step further and say,
if you're hurting your kids,
you're helping kids.
I'm not going to do that few far.
Really. I do think about that.
When your kids ask you for
something, you got to say, okay,
is this something they can do themselves?
Even if it's a struggle for them,
even if it's a challenge for them.
I mean for a while my daughter was late
for school and Oh can you just tie my
shoes? No, I can't tie your shoes.
You can tie your shoes. Right.
And that's when they work on their fine
motor skills and that's when they learn
that they can, that they have to get the
skill and they become more self reliant.
Yeah. Yeah. Fully in.
And obviously I'm not going to wage some
kind of semantical battle with you or
nothing like that, but it depends
on what you mean by help. So that,
and I talked about this before, where
you have systemic help, indirect help.
So systemic health is exactly what
you're doing. Tie your own shoes.
How about you?
How about I teach you to tie your shoes
or how would I prepare you for this shoe
tying world that you're about to
embark in? That's systemic health.
That's the real help in my opinion.
Same thing. Like a homeless person.
You give a homeless person a dollar
that's direct health, that doesn't help,
that's hurting them as you would.
So what is that called?
Direct cal direct to give your children
direct around Systemic Hill you,
your job is to prepare
kids to do everything I do.
That's in a perfect world.
Everything on their own
by the time they will,
and you actually can prepare a human to
do everything on their own because at
least you prepare them to face a
challenge. Research how to overcome it,
practice overcoming it and then overcome
it. It's so easy if you teach them,
if you, if you teach them, you know,
you say you can give them a fish
or you can teach them how to fish,
you can teach them to learn
how to fish on their own.
That's what you really want to do.
Yes. That on a tee shirt. Yeah,
that's it. That's absolutely correct.
Great. So if you go the more systemic,
you could probably end up breaking it
down into maybe three things and you know,
whatever those things are,
I know they're going to have
something to do with how to think,
how to manage your emotions,
how to adapt a lot of the real basic
things that are going to in one way or
another, apply to everything. Yeah,
it's interesting that you go from,
this isn't back in the book.
I went back to the conversation back to
the book then. It's funny how you're,
you're talking about Sun Tzu or to
war and we're talking about kids,
we're talking about business,
talking about nightclubs,
talking about Jujitsu. All right,
back to the book. Now for real,
those who are called skillful leaders
of old knew how to drive a wedge between
the enemy's front and rear to prevent
cooperation between his large and small
divisions to hinder the good
troops from rescuing the bad,
the officer's from
rallying their men.
So when you are looking at your opponent,
what can you do to split them up?
What can you do to interfere with
what they're trying to make happen?
That's a skill set in its own.
So instead of worrying about
attacking you and mourn about,
I'm focused on dispersing you or
splitting you up instead of worrying about
attacking you, I'm worried about
hindering people from helping you. Hmm.
It's, it's a different way of thinking
about waging a battle. He said,
if thinking about the battle itself, what
other ways are there to go about this?
Hmm.
More creatively.
Rapidity is the essence of war.
Take advantage of the
armies of the enemies.
Unreadiness make your way by unexpected
routes and attack unguarded spots.
Okay?
Yeah. Here we go. Back to
the human side of things.
Carefully study the wellbeing of
your men and do not overtax them.
Concentrate your energy
and hoard your strength.
Keep your army continually on the move
and devise unfathomable pat plans.
Now this is interesting.
Throw your soldiers into positions
whence there is no escape and they will
prefer to fight.
They will prefer death to flight.
Okay?
Officers and men alike,
we'll put forth their utmost strength
at the critical moment.
The leader of an army acts like one who
has climbed up a height and then kicks
away the ladder behind him.
Yeah.
He carries his men deep into hostile
territory before he shows his hand.
He burns his boats and
breaks his cooking pots.
It's a second time we've heard
about those cooking pots,
obviously that depth and
that meant something back in
the day that meant it's on.
We're not coming back. We're no,
no need for dinner tonight. Right.
But that's an attitude to have. And
it's interesting, you know, this is,
this is somewhat contradictory,
some of what the other things that he
said in the book, you know, if, if the,
if the enemy is strong,
fade away.
And now he's saying put your soldiers
in a position where there's no escape.
So that's contrary. But I, I, I
understand. I think I understand.
Or the way I translate that
is if you have to put your,
if you have to accomplish something
very challenging and you have no choice,
step into it, step into
it, kick away the ladder,
break your cooking pots and let the guys
know we're not coming back from this.
We have what?
One choice and that's victory all in
thus or sorry,
without waiting to be marshaled,
the soldiers will be
constantly on the key VA.
Yeah.
Key Viva, which means, uh, who goes,
which means on watch key
Viva without waiting.
This is the important part.
Without waiting to be asked.
They will do your will
without restriction.
They will be faithful without
giving orders. They can be trusted.
Okay,
so then you get the pure decentralized
command where we're without waiting to be
asked to do something,
they're going to do it.
That's what you want your troopers to do.
They will do. You will without
restrictions, they will be faithful.
You don't have to hold onto him.
You don't have to give him commands.
You don't have to give them orders.
They're going to be faithful to you.
Okay.
Without giving orders, they
can be trusted. That's true.
Decentralized command
and that's what you want.
Yeah.
And then to wrap this one up,
unhappy is the fate of one who tries
to win his battles and succeed in his
attacks without cultivating
the spirit of enterprise.
Okay.
Meaning we want everyone to think,
hey,
we want everybody be on the same page.
Move. Not unless you see an
advantage. Use Not your troops,
unless there is something to be gained.
Fight.
Not unless the position is critical.
Again,
that's contrary to what
what I just talked about.
But I think the reason he said that
is because sometimes you have to,
sometimes you get into decisive situation.
You have to fight, you have to win.
No ruler should put troops into the
field merely to gratify his own spleen.
Yeah.
And Spleen.
When he says that,
that used to be where people thought
that the seat of emotion was so your
emotion came from your spleen.
So He's saying what you've
been saying the whole night.
No rulership put troops in the field
merely to gratify his own emotions.
And that emotion could be anything,
could be pride. It could be irritation,
beat anything.
No general should fight a battle
simply out of peak. And that's,
that's pride and ego.
It is to your advantage to make a
forward move, make a forward move
if not,
stay where you are.
Such
is the art of war,
obviously so much to be learned
from the past, from the ancients
and also it's so accessible,
but there's so many lessons to be learned.
Their lessons that if you learn their
mistakes that you don't have to make
yourself.
All you have to do
is open a book.
Eight, open your mind and you'll be there.
And I think we get now go to questions
from the interwebs. Let's do it.
But before that,
mm.
Internet stuff up,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash
Jocko and why do you want to do that?
Get some good stuff. Yeah. Good sell
supplements, shroom tech. If you're,
um, if you're into high
intensity workouts for, you know,
some prolonged period of time
gives you, gives you that, that,
that boost in that sustenance
as far as output goes. Um,
Alpha brain helps your mind work.
That's the ones that I think we,
that I recommend and the warrior bar,
Do yourself that favor in life. And I
do the Krill oil, of course, Krill oil.
I went to a meeting this week,
they had a big old stack of
warrior bars when I went,
they were in the game,
my boy Zack was in the game down there.
That'll surely enhance the meeting for
sure at warrior who did powered me up.
Also, if you get in the mood
to support this podcast,
go to Jocko podcast.com before
you shop@amazon.com click on that,
that little link there,
and you can, you know,
kind of passively support
to Jocko podcast, boom.
Or get some shirts if you
like them, Jocko, store.com
or a mug coffee mug up before the enemy.
Both.
First Question
Jocko as an overthinker,
you missed some factors.
Anxiety, low confidence, low Iq or Iq,
perfectionism and often a
failure to prioritize. Yeah,
so this is a question from
the last podcast, right?
And this guy just sent me this tweet
and I thought it was a good assessment,
right? Cause I'm not an overthinker
and maybe this guy is, and sorry,
I don't have his Twitter call
sign there, but um, and he,
maybe he's an overthinker
so he kind of knew about it.
If you don't remember the question,
you know someone that overthinks things,
they get analysis paralysis,
right?
They just start thinking and thinking and
thinking they're frozen from their own
thoughts.
Too many thoughts.
And so I thought these were good little
factors here. And it basically, to me,
it all boils down to actually fear
because if you're thinking then you're not
taking action.
And if you're not taking and there's
no consequences and if there's no
consequences and there's nothing
to be afraid of. So I think that
the overthinking can be
an excuse for actual fear.
And same thing with like, oh, I'm a
perfectionist. That's also a fear.
It's fear of not being perfect. And then
on top of that, low confidence, well,
if you have low confidence, guess what?
You're afraid your confidence is low,
you're not sure yourself.
So you sit around and think about
doing it instead of actually doing it
and then anxiety. Well, yeah,
anxiety actually is fear.
You're afraid to do something.
And then Iq. Now that might be,
I guess maybe someone has a High Iq
and therefore they're thinking a lot.
And maybe that's not fear, but let me
ask you a question. If you're so smart,
then why aren't you taking the
action and making something happen?
So you've got a big Iq that's no excuse
to sit around and overthink things,
especially because if you're so smart,
why can't you come up with a quick
solution to why can't you realize that
overthinking is actually
causing the problem harm?
It's not moving the problem forward.
So quit thinking so much and take action.
Next question. Okay. He's,
he's talking about the Tim Ferris,
the video with the extension
of your Tim Ferris. Yeah. Yeah.
You're talking about martial
arts or martial arts. What
are the best martial art?
If you haven't seen that
and you can look it up. Um,
so he says with respect to the above
mentioned video about your views on real
martial arts.
I have one quick question.
You said that you came to your conclusion
based on a sparring match between
yourself in one of your fellow navy
seals with the match between yourself and
the traditional martial arts with 20 years
experience of friendly sparring match
typical and training where he was pulling
his punches and strikes and strikes or
was he attacking you with full force?
From my observation,
Jujitsu guys collect some headshots
while going in for a takedown.
And if a traditional cut,
a tikka karate practitioner
doesn't hold back with this health,
some devastating effects in the long run.
Similar to what pro
football's players experience.
I would love to get your take on this.
Someone who is real world experience.
Okay.
So first of all,
I didn't come to a conclusion
based on that one event.
I mean that event influenced my
thoughts today, but even right now,
I don't have a conclusion.
Someone could show me something today.
It's possible that I go, wow, that worked
really well. I never thought of that.
And that's new dot. Now trumps everything
else. It could happen. Not Likely though.
Uh, my mind is still open, but that's
not like they have seen a lot now.
And that's particular scenario. He was
usually, he wasn't using a striking,
aren't a traditional striking her
and he was using the grappling aren't
actually I kido and so he,
he was grappling with me.
He wasn't throwing punches at me,
but it doesn't matter
because I have sparred and,
or fought with plenty of people over the
years that we're absolutely trying to
knock me out,
no doubt about it.
And the fact of the matter
is it doesn't work. Um,
even where this guy above
like for instance, this guy
and the question he says,
if a traditional karate
practitioner doesn't hold back,
it would have the same devastating
effect in the long run.
Similar to what pro
football players experience.
That statement actually defeats itself
because if you watch a football game,
those guys get hit in the head the
hundred times during a football game.
And how often do they get actually
knocked unconscious? Not very often.
If you multiply whatever 10 players per
side that are actually banging heads
times, however, and he plays,
you know, you're talking
about thousand Mo, you know,
probably more than a thousand head on
head contacts and a football game and
there might be one knockout in a game.
Sometimes there's no knockouts. Yeah,
typically not.
The fact of the matter is a hitting
someone in the head is not a guaranteed
knock out by any stretch of the
imagination. In fact, it rarely occurs.
It actually rarely curves in boxing
where two guys are trained to do that.
So it's hard to knock somebody out and
it's the same thing if you watch UFC,
especially the early UFC. Yes. This was
proven over and over again that yeah,
the dude grapplers going to
take some hits on the way in,
but they're going to get in and they're
going to take the person down and of,
of course, do you have a puncher's
chance? Of course you do.
There is this a very small chance that
when you shoot it on somebody they time
and knee,
are they time a punch and it happens to
hit you right in the spot that knocks
you out? It does happen. It
happens in UFC occasionally.
If you look at the number of take downs
to the number of knockouts that happened
while the take down is going on, it's
not a big number at all. Correct.
So you don't want to rely on that as
your formation of self defense at all.
Now when things evolved eventually to
where the strikers were wrestlers to and
you got guys like chuck and you've got
Tito and you got Randy where it wasn't
their striking that was
preventing the takedown.
It was because they
were bad ass wrestlers.
That's what was stopping to take down.
It had nothing to do with
the way they punched. Yeah,
so you really can't count on
striking to stop a grappler.
That is not a good plan to say,
Hey,
I'm going to get so good at striking
that I'm going to stop a grappler that is
not a good pant plant.
Well you have to do is learn to grapple.
You have to learn to wrestle,
you have to learn Jujitsu. And,
and the opposite side of that is you
can't count on grappling to take down a
striker because you that
might know how to wrestle
and therefore you need
to know how to strike.
So it goes back to what
I say all the time.
You got to know how to graph and
governor not a strike. Right? Yeah.
And if he's um,
he's talking,
he says a traditional karate practitioner,
traditional.
So,
and I'm assuming the,
the only understanding of traditional
is he doesn't do karate and Jujitsu.
He's not a mixed martial artist.
He just knows karate. So,
yes. And I've taken crowded before
and there was no take down defense.
There was no takedowns,
there was no functioning in
any capacity on the ground.
And so
yeah,
and how you say like, okay,
over the longterm, okay,
you're going to have head trauma and
lasting damage if you take sustained head
trauma,
repetitive over the years,
really we're worried about the
next 42 seconds of the fight.
That's about to happen,
not the next three decades of my life
where you can definitely break down.
Cause I took some head trauma.
Exactly right. So you'd have to get,
let's say that for the example of this
question that your experience with this
guy,
he was a karate guy and he was going
full speed and he didn't knock you out.
We'll just assume that he didn't
knock you up. You'd have to go.
I'm just going to restate that.
That is a very safe assumption to assume
that the karate guy was not able to
knock me out, that I was able
to come in, you know, uh,
a stand there. Good. Get it a good
distance. Faking with my hands,
touch his face a couple of times.
He throws a big punch.
I do a double leg take down,
he's on his back. It's game
over. Yeah. And by the way,
go watch any youtube video of,
you know,
Jujitsu versus whatever. Right. And
it's the same outcome every single time.
You know, occasionally there'll be one
with a lot of hits because it's the,
it's the chance knockout or the chance
or something else happened. Yeah.
But 99% of the time it's double
leg take down slam on the ground.
Game over. Yeah. Sorry.
You can look at uh,
who did Randy coach or a fight that
pro boxer Tony James Toney. Yeah,
I mean it was, it was that exactly.
Here's you a a worldclass boxer.
A professional boxer. What did Randy
do? God inside took him down. Came over.
Oh why didn't you knock them out?
Cause you can't, right. You can't just,
you can't just knock people out fully.
And that's not to mention,
and I'm,
I mean I'm going to mention it but that
it is not to mention that especially if
you,
if you practice the more self defense,
like if it's heavily self
defense oriented Jujitsu,
one of the first things you
learn is distance management.
One of the first things you learn,
it's like you almost can't
get past that element of it.
So you will take hits. Of course. Maybe
you will take it to the top of your head,
shoulders or whatever.
But yes,
significant strikes to anything to warrant
how it's stated here in the question.
Um, long term term damage
compared to football players.
You back to your situation,
you going with this guy,
let's say he did go full speed,
you would have to do probably 10 to 15
bouts of that every single day for a long
time for you to have any sustained damage.
And then so maybe if this guy is taking
the long term strategic view that you
should get to continuous bar me and hit
me in the head until I'm 50 years old
navy elistic disease.
And maybe I'm saying maybe so.
Cause if he's a traditional guy, he
doesn't know how to manage the takedown.
So knowing how to manage the takedown
makes your strikes more effective.
You don't have that.
Your strikes are not effective.
So can you take one hit let's say,
let's say you take five hits, right?
You controlling the fight
as much as Jujitsu does,
even if you're not that high level versus
the guy who doesn't know Jujitsu way
outweighs this grossly to the point
that these things are aside from the
puncher's chance in effective and I think
UFC one two three you know as before
people start to get hip to
the whole Jujitsu thing,
but before people knew Jujitsu,
they just knew there are other
stuff that was the testing ground.
That was the whole reason you'll
see was invented by the way on.
That's why those first few
of are awesome. Yeah, you,
you get to see these 250 and no
bare knuckle kick boxer guys strong,
you know,
go in there with real quote unquote
real fighting experience against the way
smaller grappler Jujitsu
guy and lose and it's act.
This is to go one step further. If you
watch UFC too. Pat Smith, who's I want,
he was one of my favorite guys by the way
when I was watching. It's a kickboxer.
He's bad ass guy to 10 solid racking guys,
makes it to the finals against hoists.
Gracie and hoists.
Gracie didn't tap him out or he tapped
them out. But now with a submission hold,
he tapped him due to strikes.
So grappler pounded out a striker guy.
I'm not submissions. It was
all punches. It was nowadays,
no one would ever talk to that now.
But I'm just saying only because
they know if you don't know,
you just think your dad. Yeah.
Yeah. One guy, like I said before,
long I tapped because he was
claustrophobic. He just got
mounted. But nonetheless,
um, yeah, it's,
it's hard to really reconcile
really what this question,
I don't know if it's implying anything.
Well,
it's definitely implying that this guy
that I was going against was like holding
back. Right. And that might, uh, you
know, pull the different tale if,
but I've been against countless,
literally countless of guys have
sparred against me trying to talk me out
whether they're traditional
martial artists, whether
they're just countless guys.
Yeah. And it's hard to knock somebody
out. Yeah. And I dunno, I don't know who,
that's the question.
Of course,
I'm not going to hate on the
question or nothing like that.
But speaking from experience,
this sounds like the exact question that
inexperienced people have. You know,
people who are,
no,
this is coming most likely from
something that's been heavily involved in
traditional martial arts
and has been told that, hey,
don't worry about somebody trying to
take you down because if you just hit him
here and here or they'll fall and you'll
win. That's what I'm talking about.
That's
not, that's not good. That's sort of
why I put this in here. And you know,
just to make sure that, um, that
they realize that hey, you shouldn't,
you should actually pay attention to what
else is going on in the world instead
of staying in like, Hey, just this
one little traditional martial art.
And it's the same thing with, if you're
just doing Jujitsu and we're going to,
I got this in here and later, there's
another question about this, but I mean,
I don't tell people just trained Jujitsu.
I tell him, train, Jujitsu, change,
wrestling, trained boxing chain,
Moy, Tai, and you know what?
When you get done with all that and you
have a good base train Krav Maga and
then you, you know what do
realistic situation, by the way,
you should learn how to shoot a gun and
by the way, you should be in good shape.
Do everything. Yeah. Yeah. Agreed.
The answer is not the answer.
Yeah.
Okay.
T shirt.
Every time we say something like that,
like one answer is not the answer,
which I must admit, it sounds pretty
cool. Pretty Dope. But we'll get,
everyone's going to say, put
that on a tee shirt. Hey,
then I have to refer to echo to see if
he's going to put it on a tee shirt. Yup.
We'll see how that works out.
All right. Next question.
Is it better to reveal too much
information or too little information?
Both in personal life and leadership.
Okay,
so there's two sides to this,
not just the personal and
the business side, but in,
in the business side, there's two pieces
really. There's operational and planning,
right? So if you've got something
that you're planning for,
whether you're a company and you're
trying to plan a new strategy for the next
quarter,
the next year or the next company that
you're going to open or the Newco,
whatever you're going to do,
there's that and you're planning that.
Then I want to, and and in the military,
if you're planning an operation,
you're putting together a mission
that you're going to go do.
In both those situations, I give
everyone all the information that I have.
Absolutely.
I don't.
I let them know everything that I
know so that they can away everything.
As much as I wait. In fact,
I want them to toil with the,
with the information more than I do so
that I can kind of get a fresher look at
it when I come in.
So I,
and I think I do and I did see people
that would hold back information in those
situations. Leaders that would hold back
information. Why would they do that?
Because they're insecure because
knowledge gives you power and you use that
knowledge to say you come in and echoes,
got a good plan put together. And I go,
yeah, but you got to think about this
right here. And you just say, well,
I didn't know that,
but it gives me a little bit of leverage.
It gives me a little bit of power.
That's ridiculous.
So when it comes to planning
and operations and conducting
business and planning
missions, man, share all the information
you've got in your organization,
out of the organization.
So everybody has the knowledge.
That's answer number one.
Then we get to the information
regarding the leadership of humans.
Yeah.
And of course you hear
words like transparency and
we gotta be honest and you
can hear those things
getting thrown around and,
and of course no one's going
to argue with them, right?
No one's going to argue and say,
hey, you shouldn't be honest.
No one's going to say you
shouldn't be transparent. Right.
But the fact of the matter is you cannot
always share all the information all
the time when it comes to leading people.
You can't do it.
Okay.
And here's the problem of why you can't
do it because people can't always handle
the truth.
Hmm.
Yeah.
And when you give them the truth, they
might have a bunch of different reactions.
Right? Some of those reactions being anger
and defensiveness. So in other words,
if I tell someone,
hey,
I'm putting this other person in charge
cause I don't think you're smart enough
to figure out the solution.
Yeah, that's my true statement.
I'm going to be honest with you. I don't
think you're smart. What does that do?
How does that affect the mission? Does
it move us closer to the goal? Are you,
is that person now going to be really
supportive of me and work hard knowing
that I think they're stupid.
The answers, of course not.
Okay.
I mean another example is what if you
think that your boss is planned is
terrible. And so you go in there and
say, Hey, your boss is terrible. Your,
your plan that you came up with is awful.
Now,
there might be some bosses that are secure
and their leadership and their secure
with it and they go, aw man, why do you
think that here? Break it down for me.
That's cool. But a lot of bosses
are going to be insulted by that.
A lot of bosses, you're going to hurt
their ego and instead of listening to the,
to the idea that you have,
instead they're going to be angered by it.
They are going to turn it off,
they're going to turn off,
their minds are going to be mad at you.
They're not going to
listen to you anymore.
Cause the way you came across so
you would have been better off.
Okay.
Not being quote unquote honest and
not sharing all the information,
you would have been better off slowly
trying to take the plan that he came up
with and maybe maneuver on
it or maybe say, hey boss,
I don't know if that's gonna work
because of this thing over here.
But you be tactful
and there's a million examples
we could talk of like that.
And so when it comes to leading people,
not operations,
not planning missions, when it comes
to leading people, you need to think,
think about what you're saying, thinking
of how it's going to impact the team.
Think about how it's gonna impact the
relationships up and down the chain of
command. Think about how it's
going to impact the mission.
Because if you're a good leader,
anywhere on that,
anywhere in that chain of command,
if you're a good leader,
the most important thing you
should be achieving the mission.
So if your honesty is actually creating
adversarial relationships inside your
team, what good are you doing
moving the mission forward?
The answer is you're not.
Hmm.
Okay.
So I'm not telling you to be dishonest,
but I'm you to think,
and it's the same thing
in your personal life.
You got to think about what you're saying.
You got to think about your wife's
perspective or your husbands perspective,
where your kid's perspective
or your friend's perspective.
Yeah,
how is what I'm about to say
going to affect them long term.
You gotta be measured. Now you might
give them a little hint of something
and then see how they react.
And maybe you could be a little
bit more honest with them.
Maybe you could throw some bait out
there and see if they bite on it,
but you just don't want to jump in or
throw it out to where now you've created
an adversarial relationship with your
friend, with your spouse, with your kids,
because now they're not listening to
it's even with your kids or you got to be
totally honest with your kids. Okay.
You know what? Totally. Honestly,
I don't think you're capable of being
this level of an athlete. Right?
Do they need to hear that when they're
nine years old? Probably not. Mm hmm.
So you just gotta think you gotta think,
and there's a ways to get that
information across in a tactical way,
in an indirect way so that it's
still manages to improve the person.
Because I don't want to have echo come up.
Will you come up with a bunch of
bad ideas? And all I do is say, oh,
that's a good idea. That's a good
idea. That's good. I didn't train you,
I didn't improve you. I want to say,
hey, you know what, that's not bad.
What if we did this? You know what I mean?
And so we move in the right direction.
We still have some mentorship going on,
but it's indirect.
We still have some coaching going on,
but it's indirect because I don't want
to coach you and you don't want to be
coached by me.
Even my son when I like tell
him something in Jujitsu,
I've been doing Jujitsu for over 20
years with some of the best guys in the
entire world literally. And I'll say, hey,
thought you need to scoot your hip a
little bit more when you do that move.
And he'd go, no, you don't
really know actually you do it. What
he'll listen to Jeff. Hey listen to dean.
Actually you won't actually, I've heard
him argue with both Jeff and dean.
He's navy with their approach.
Yeah.
Maybe they can give you a little more
indirect. Correct, Doug Man. Yup.
And that kind of illustrates one
of the many challenges with that.
Um, you know, one of the simple but not
easy things because everyone's different.
How you saying throw something out
there and see how they respond.
Everyone's going to respond different.
That's the thing.
So it is kind of this feeling out
process. It's, you know, I think that,
and I mentioned this before where,
you know,
some people they'll be direct but people
don't really like him and then they,
they dealt kind of doubled down on it and
say, Hey, you know, I, I speak the truth,
you know, and like me for who I am or
whatever. So what you do when you do that,
when people do that is the
render themselves ineffective in,
in situations now, no one's leadership.
Exactly right. And guess what?
No one's who might each of their party,
no one wants to be your friend. You know,
you may or may not have gotten a divorce
from it and it's all because you check,
essentially you just chose to be a dick.
We all understand that certain things
are insulting if you're quote unquote to
on, you know everyone except
you, you know, you're the,
if you look around and no one wants to
be around you, that's a problem. Yeah.
Newsflash, you're a jerk. Yes. And inch.
And people don't follow jerks.
They really don't. Yeah. Yeah.
So it's not an isn't it? Honesty is never
an excuse to be a jerk to people. Yeah.
And don't mistake,
you know how people have this kind of
misconception that speaking your mind is a
good thing. It's not black and white.
You're totally right. Don't be like, Hey,
I know that's what's so
crazy about this is like, um,
people I think always have that feeling.
I mean,
I said it when I was talking, you know,
people say, oh, of course, honesty is,
you know, the best thing and you gotta
be honest. And I would say that I am,
I am known as a person that is
honest and a straight shooter
and that's great.
But at the same time,
like you just said, that doesn't
mean I run around. It insults people.
It means I'm a tactician. You know
what, it's not honesty. It's tat.
It's being a tactician because w this is
something that can actually go too far
as well. Um, if,
if you're constantly always telling
him everyone thing every year,
all sugarcoated. Well now the no one
respects your opinion either, right?
You just hear him saying, you
know, if I just say, oh, Echo,
you did a great job with that video.
You did a great job with that video too.
You did great. Well, what if you
were producing junk video, sad exam?
I need to tell you. Yeah, I
know. It's a rough example. Uh,
I would need to think of something that
you didn't do such high quality point
take. No, for sure.
I've gotta I've gotta be honest with
you and if all I do is tell you, hey,
it's great, it's great, it's great, it's
great, it's great, it's great. You know,
that doesn't help us. What I need to say
is, hey man, that's an awesome video.
It'd be cool if you captured
this angle too, right?
Or do you think it'd be possible to get
this message across also and you'd say,
Oh, I can do anything. You
see how I just played Eureka?
Then you see what I did that,
yeah. Hey. Yeah, like I'll,
do you think it's even possible to get
this angle in there and you'd be like,
Oh yeah, I could make it
come across strong. Dang.
I didn't even know there was a fight.
He didn't just what?
I just had a little victory
up in here. All right. Yeah,
so it's not black and white or like
like everything. It's a balance.
It's all balanced sense of dichotomy
psychotomy between telling the truth and
being tactful.
Next question,
Jocko.
How do you handle
it? When someone up the chain
of command betrays trust,
like what is this like lying? They lied
to you or this could be, this is a huge,
this is a huge spectrum of,
I guess for number one you just learned,
you just learned something
about someone's character. Yeah.
You now kind of know better
what you're dealing with. Now,
if this is a major situation,
you might have to immediately confronted
and or go above them and the chain of
command, I mean, if there's lives at risk,
if there's something morally
wrong that is happening,
if there's something illegal that's
happening that now you're going to get
wrapped into, and that's another
decision you got to make.
If you're not going to be wrapped into it,
then it's a decision you've got to make.
If you want to ruin this person's life,
whatever, that's that's a different
decision. That's not this question.
We'd have to deal with that
in a separate question. Mm.
Are innocent people being hurt? So if, if
it's something like that, lives at risk,
you know, something morally wrong is
happening, something illegal is happening,
innocent people being hurt,
then you're probably going to have to
say something or you're going to have to
say something. Now, I will tell
you this before you say something,
make sure all your ducks in a
row made sure you have evidence.
Don't go off half cocked.
Be Ready.
Because people that are deceitful
like this, they, they, they prepare,
they are ready for battle
to protect themselves and
they don't care what happens
to other people.
So you've got to watch out for that.
Now if it's something really, if
it's something minor, you know,
if it's something minor,
then
okay,
that's something that you logged
down and in the brain, right?
Something that you logged
down in the brain and
MMM.
But it allows you to see person's
character. And that means, again,
it's a minor infraction,
but it also means you got
to watch yourself and you
got to watch them a little
bit more closely. You gotta be
careful because people like that,
they think they're smarter
than everyone else.
They think that they're
getting away with why.
So they think they're smarter
than, there's like a little
hint of sociopath. Yeah.
In there that they can
get away with these lies.
And so you got to watch him.
You got to watch him.
Okay.
Carefully in, in, like I said, it kind
of goes back to that previous question
because you don't want to be a person
that comes across as dishonest yourself.
And if people don't think they
can trust what you're saying,
they're not going to trust you
with other things. So if you know,
I'm not giving you good
feedback because I'm too nice,
you're not going to start you, you're
not going to respect my opinion anymore.
Right. So you know, when you're,
when you're dealing with someone, if
someone comes to you instead of getting,
this is honesty versus if
you come to me and say, Hey,
what do you think of this plant?
I'm not going to say, Hey,
I think that's a stupid plan.
Okay.
I might say, I don't know if that's how I
do it. I might try this approach. Right?
You're just going to be diplomatic. If
you, if I'm not going to say to you,
I don't think you're smart
enough to figure this out.
I have moved you to a different division
cause I don't think you're smart enough
to solve this problem. I'm not going to
say that. I'm going to say, you know what?
I need you on this other project over
here that I think you're going to be
really knock this thing out of the park.
Hmm.
Now you're getting to know deep inside.
Okay.
But it's called tact and
that's what you have to use.
But back to the honesty or when person
betrays your trust, you've learned,
you've learned about their character.
If it's a big thing,
you're going to have to talk about it.
You're gonna have to tell somebody. Yeah.
It's a little thing.
You got to watch TV. I think we just
learned that vocabulary tonight.
Who's their watch?
Hmm. Yeah. The, you know how you
see and you log it in your brain,
right? Logging in your brain that, okay,
they lied about that. Or Oh, I, you know,
I think you should constantly do that.
Right. And I think we all do that anyway.
That that's really, I think that's
why. And your brain has certain ways,
um, just the way it's wired,
like first impressions, right.
That's usually a big thing.
But really what's really going on isn't
that the first impression is this has
more weight specifically.
Then you know,
other other impressions
that you get along the line.
It's because let's say you don't, let's
say, I don't know that much about you.
I don't know really. This is the first
time I ever met you heard about you,
whatever your first impression. It's
not that it's so heavy, it's just,
it's the only impression. So it seems
like everything. If you're a dick to me,
okay, you're a dick in my mind you're
just a dick. Second Day you're not a Dick,
you're 50% Dick, which is,
that's still a day, you know?
Even if you're 20% Dick, you're like,
okay, I like them buddies still the day,
you know. So again, my point is you're
always logging stuff in your brain.
What does this person,
what does this person not when it comes
to someone who betrayed your trust,
this doesn't really count them
out as far as trusting them.
Cause a lot of times the more
time you spend with them,
the more experience you have with them,
you start to get a picture of, okay,
he'll be trained. My trust, in this
case, in this type of situation,
it's like if you have a friend who he
would literally risk his life to save your
life, but at the same time
he would probably hook up
with your wife if he had the
opportunity, you know? So there's
different kinds of things.
So as you gain experience with people,
therefore risking his own
life, right? Sure. Of course.
But you start to get a
picture of who the person,
and I don't have any friends like that.
Yeah.
But I do know what you're saying.
There's people that have different
moral compass and moral and so
you're judging them based
on that, right? Yeah.
So just be careful not to judge him
based on that. So again, based on,
we'll see, but that's part
of like this big picture. So,
cause ultimately you
want to get to the point,
and I've had this experience specifically
in my life before where, you know,
you want to get to the point
where you trust them. Yeah.
I trust them to be that person. You know?
I know he's not trustworthy in this,
but he's just wear this. So I, yeah,
his role in my life or in
this company or whatever.
I know I trust him to be him, that
therefore I won't give them this task.
You trust that he's going to
have them. Yes, exactly. Right.
I host the Scorpion to be the Scorpion
stings the frog to be the frog. Yes.
And that comes with like the experience.
So if someone, you know, like you said,
if it's a minor thing,
don't go jumped down his throat or just
jump to this thing. Really just be like,
okay, you know, deal with it
in your way. But like I said,
log in in your brain and move forward
what you know and keep your eyes open to
things that you can trust them above
so you can get that full picture.
And I hate to say this
and I've said it before,
I don't have these massively high
expectations of other human beings. Yeah.
I hate to say it,
but I'm kind of anticipating that
they're telling me half truths. Yeah.
And Yeah.
Yeah.
So don't get these high expectations and
expect that people are going to try and
get one over on you.
Yeah.
And then when you do get your core of
people that you know are really truly
trustworthy, that's awesome. Yeah. That
might be three people in your life. Yeah.
Yeah. And that's, I would say that
that's, that's fair. You know,
I think a lot of people are like that
and I think everyone's like that in one
way or another. You know?
And it's a spectrum.
But I've been in a situation where
someone say, Hey, do you know this guy?
He'll be like, yeah, yeah, yeah,
I know. There'll be like, yeah,
you're friends with that guy, isn't
he hard to trust because of like this.
And I'll say,
I don't find them hard to trust.
I trust him to be him.
And just exactly how you're saying you
trust the Scorpion to be a scorpion. Yeah.
You know,
Scorpion can be relied upon for specific
things and straight up can't be relied
upon for certain other things.
So again,
if you just keep your
eyes open and you know,
don't start burning
bridges with the person.
If it's this small thing
as as time goes on,
you can start to get a feel of really
who this person is in the entirety and it
might be beneficial in the
in the situation you're in
with them. No, your people.
I agree.
Next question.
Here's a strange one.
I have ongoing regret for never joining
the military or police department and
I'm not yet strong enough to consider
changing careers now for financial
reasons.
I also don't know how to discuss this
with my wife as we want to make some
additions to the family soon.
I feel unfulfilled in the
single aspect of my life.
It's a strange feeling considering I have
skyrocketed up the chain in my company
so quickly,
so many would do anything
to be where I find myself.
How do you overcome your face or how do
you overcome or face yourself knowing
you're holding back from a certain
calling because I really do see it as a
calling in some form.
I'm interested to hear from you.
I think this is pretty easy. Go join
the reserves. Hmm. Go join the reserves.
Go in the army reserves,
go in there.
Like every branch has some reserves where
you're going to do one weekend a month,
you have to do bootcamp,
that'll be whatever it's going
to be 10 weeks, 12 weeks,
14 weeks depending on
which branch you go into.
And then you do one weekend a month and
you do two weeks in the summer. You,
you'll understand what the military
is about. There's actually a chance,
well first of all, there's a
chance you'd be deployed. I mean,
when we were in Iraq, you know,
when we deployed to Ramadi,
my second deployment to Iraq,
the, the unit that was there,
the two to eight iron soldiers, they
were reserve unit out of Pennsylvania.
They were awesome and they'd been doing
that for 14 months and they lost a lot
of guys and they fought hard.
So it's not like this reserve is thing is,
is is a different class a soldier,
they're soldiers for real.
They're marines for real.
Then you may be going on deployment.
But what's cool about it is most
companies, they will excuse you.
Basically when you go in the reserves,
they'll excuse you when you have time.
And in fact, I think it's,
I was never in the reserves,
but I think you're actually protected by
the federal government from being fired
because you're serving in the reserves.
So I would definitely go and look into
the reserves because otherwise that
feeling that you have, I can only
imagine it's never going to go away.
I don't know.
Because I had that feeling that I wanted
to do in the military when I was four
years old and I did it as soon
as I turned 18. So I don't,
you know, I, I, you know what
I regret now, I was like,
I want to still be in. Huh.
You know? So especially now with
the fighting picking up overseas,
it's uh, you know, that's, that's the
only thing that, that I feel is, damn,
I want to go back. But if you never did
it at all, that's a grinding feeling.
So go talk to recruiter, getting
the reserves and you know what else?
In certain areas there's definitely
volunteer fire departments. Yeah,
you can volunteer as a fireman and
you can volunteer as a policeman.
They have certain, uh, I dunno,
I have no idea what state you're
from asking this question.
But there's deputies you can get
deputized, you can go through a,
in San Diego they definitely have reserve
cops where you have to go to school,
you have to go to the police academy
and you become a reserve cop. So,
and with all that
you want to talk about it with your wife.
Talk about with your wife, you
know, you say you don't know how to,
this isn't a situation where you
can be totally honest with her. Hey,
I always wanted to join the military.
I haven't done it.
I feel like it's something
I really want to do.
Here's the options I want to go look
at. What do you think? Now you're,
you're married, you're married to
a and you're going to have kids.
It's your military service will be
harder on her than it is on you.
So she better be strong, she
better be tough. And you know,
the military wives out there,
I mean my wife,
when I was gone and deployment after
deployment, it's, it's not easy.
I mean luckily she's tough and she raised
kids without me and she took care of
household without me and she went to the
hospital to visit my wounded guys and
she went to the funerals of my guys were
getting killed and she had to do that
while I was gone on deployment.
And I was,
she was hearing from me once a week maybe.
So you're gonna put your
family through a lot of stress.
Now you might stress your family a lot
by always having regret that they held
you back. That's selfish. But that's true.
So I would just go look into it,
see what the options are,
talk about it with your wife.
There are some really good benefits to it.
And also the final point is
sometimes when you're reservist,
you can decide that you want to go active
duty. Maybe you love it. Maybe you say,
yeah,
this was my calling.
Maybe you're fourth day in boot
camp where you haven't slept.
You had your head shaved, you're tired,
you're hungry, the food is horrible.
And you say, man, this is what I've
always wanted to do with my life.
And if that happens, there's options
where you can now go active duty and,
and you can see how your wife dealt with
it while you were gone and she dealt
with it. Well that's great. Hey,
let's make a career out of this
and that's a good option. Yeah.
And to do so there's some, I
think you're, this is, this is,
this is an easy day, easy, easy
problem to take care of. No factor.
Interesting.
Next question Jocko.
What's your take on sport
Jujitsu versus self defense?
Jujitsu and can support Transport Jujitsu?
Can it translate onto the street?
Most schools are geared towards sport.
Yeah.
So for anyone that's listening
that doesn't do Jujitsu,
both of you that are out there, that
don't do together listening, first of all,
do Jujitsu. Uh, second of all. So there's,
there's Jujitsu is rooted really in self
defense and like anything that gets put
into a,
a closed environment,
it starts to breed and
become different and mutate.
And so Jujitsu in a way,
what they called,
what they now call sport Jujitsu is
Jujitsu that has been in this competition
environment, in the Jujitsu
sport competition environment.
So Jujitsu is a sport
as well as self defense.
It's a sport with points and you can win
on points and they have championships
and it's very competitive and it's,
it's pretty entertaining to watch
if you know and understand the game.
But since it's in this environment,
this closed environment,
it starts to mutate.
And that's what's happened.
So for instance,
there is maneuvers that you do in,
in Sport Jujitsu that are so
intricate and they're so reliant on,
for instance, reliant on the
Geeky, that Jujitsu uniform,
which is a heavy fabric [inaudible].
And you can actually use parts
of the Geeky to choke people.
And you can use parts of the Geeky to,
uh,
make a person off balance
called a sweep and get on top.
You can literally take the lapel of their
key and put it between their legs and
wrap it around your leg and then grab
the geeky there and it's gonna and then
you just swing your hips and is
going to pull them off balance.
Now this is something you could
literally never do in the street.
So that's what they're talking about
when they're talking about sport versus
self defense.
And they have this with other things.
I mean there's sport shooting
where they do certain and it's,
it's semi realistic. Just
like Jujitsu, semi realistic.
When you go in a tournament,
it's somewhat simulates a street fight,
just like some shooting competitions,
somewhat simulate combat,
but they're not exact.
And so the question is,
does the sport translate onto the street?
And my answer to that
is, first of all, yes,
it does. Not every move, certainly,
and there's absolutely moves that you
would do in Jujitsu in a tournament that
you would never do on the street.
Now luckily anybody who's good enough to
do those advanced moves in a tournament
is good enough that in the street,
they're not going to need those moves.
You're not going to need to do a
reverse Alma Plata in the street.
You're not going to need to do,
um,
donkey guard in the street.
[inaudible] right?
You're not going to need to do
bear and Bolo in the street.
You're just not going to need to do it.
If you're fighting someone that
that's good, well then guess what?
I guess you didn't need it,
but you're not going to come up against
a person in the street that's going to
have a counter to your bare and Bolo
attack and you don't have a Guianan.
So that's not going to work. I mean,
there are some Nogi versus that.
The bottom line is if
you're doing Jujitsu, you're
definitely going to do very,
very well in a street fight.
Now that being said,
that being said,
sometimes you know what you gotta do.
You gotta train Jujitsu for the street.
You got to, you got to punch each other.
Occasionally you got to
say, Hey, you know what?
Let's go live a little bit and we'll
do some, maybe you put gloves on.
Maybe you put MMA gloves on.
Maybe just use open hands and you smack
each other and you realize like, Oh,
when I'm on the bottom and the half
guard where I feel super comfortable when
I'm doing Jujitsu,
if I'm in a real fight,
I'm going to be getting headbutted or
I'm going to be getting punched in the
face and that's not good. So what
do I do to get out of this? Um,
do you know, even in the guard can
be horrible on the bottom. Yeah. Um,
did you don't want to be on the bottom
anyways in a fight. You
don't want to, you don't.
The bottom line is you don't want to
grapple if you don't have to. Yeah.
You don't want to be in a
street fight in the first place.
The reason you're in a street
place cause you could not avoid it.
That's why you're in a street fight. You
could not avoid it. You got attacked,
you got taken down to the ground because
even if someone swings at you and you
can still get away from you, they
haven't grabbed you yet. Runaway. Cool.
So train Jujitsu with punches. Also
trained boxing, wartime wrestling.
And also work on some real scenarios.
Work on the headlock and I've seen this,
where do you get a a guy that's really
just come into the game and jump straight?
You know these young kids, they
come into the game, they start,
the first thing they want to
learn is the rubber guard.
The first thing they want
to learn is the Omoplata.
The first thing they want to
learn is it bare and Bolo.
That's like the first
thing they want to learn.
And literally someone will put them in a
headlock and they won't know what to do
because it's different.
Just like just like a bear and
Bolo requires to neck technique.
The headlock escape requires some
technique to get out of that.
So work on that.
Work on the bear hug,
work on the the arm grab and the risk
grab and the the the straight arm choke in
big looping punches that you're gonna see.
And I'll tell you sometimes dean
will teach a self defense class.
And when Dean teaches a self defense
class, every time he teaches one,
I learned something. I'm like, man,
that's a good little technique.
He just showed how to get out of
this, how to get out of that. So
bottom line, yes, you can, it it,
sport Jujitsu for the most part
translates into the street.
And if you're good enough at Sports
Jujitsu that you're competing at a high
level, even purple belt in up, you're
not going to need to use any sports.
Jujitsu moves in the street,
you're going to be destroying
somewhat in a street fight. Yeah.
If you end up in that situation. Yeah.
The, the, it's a Spec, especially now,
just like, are you saying the Jujitsu
has evolved and kind of mutated,
morphed, um, in,
in the gyms now a petri dish Jujitsu's
that can, a petri dish, it's growing.
It just grows on its own.
It turns in this weird fungus and it gets
all different looking and it does look
different. Yeah. It does look
different than it did. You
know, even like, I remember,
I remember Dean when I were
talking about the other day,
we would remember when the
Omoplata came out. Hmm. You know,
I think it was like 1996 we started
seeing the Oma plot and we, oh man.
And it looks very fancy.
It looks very,
it's a fancy looking move and now,
now because of the Internet,
because so many people are,
it's exploding how rapidly
it's changing and mutating.
It's mutating faster now
than it ever has. Yeah, yeah.
And that's part of the beauty of it
I think in, you know, in most ways,
um, the, it's a spectrum though,
right? If you went from one side,
which is just the basic,
the original basic,
you know, take down mountain
side, Mount Guard, all this,
all the way to worm guard
something that that or,
or baron bullet for example,
where, so sport, Jujitsu,
if you want to narrow it
down, it's, it's, it's,
if it's something where the moves or
whatever you're doing is dependent on the
sport elements of it.
So it's dependent that you have a mat,
it's dependent that you have a g
and a belt. So if you do warm guard,
that's highly dependent on the guy
having a geeky with the lapel out.
And eventually someone's going to figure
out how to do warm guard without it.
They'll figure out some variation for
sure. They may have already. Yeah. Yeah.
So it should Keenan's working
on the pioneer. So, um,
it's like, you know, just to kind
of put it into define terms, right,
so self defense I think now is you may
find a gym that's only does sport where
if you came in no experience and then you
know, three, four or five years later,
your sport Jujitsu might not take
you very far in the street. It's,
it'd be rare I think. But you could
probably find the school like that.
I don't know where they are but,
but I think just like what you're saying,
when you make it to purple belt,
you're the basic Jujitsu.
We'll win on the street. And
really when, if you go to a school,
like even though the original Gracie
academy in Torrance, if you go there,
the self,
the self defense pursuit in Jujitsu
is more of it is it's tactic based.
Like mentally it's not specific moves.
It's distance management.
It's where your mindset is in the
guard. Your, your, your pursuit,
your goal in the guard is way different
than in a, in a tournament or something.
They won't, they'll say don't even
go for submissions right here.
It's not your job to do
submissions right here.
I was going to say that you said is
dependent on the gates to sports you use
depending on the Guid,
depending on the mat,
it's also dependent on the rules and
spending it on an opponent that knows
Jujitsu.
Yes.
Depended on somebody that knows what
they're doing cause they're going counter
of what you're doing in order to make
something work. Absolutely right. Yeah.
So the,
if you go back to the self defense,
you're going to be learning basically how
to protect yourself given what Jujitsu
is. That's, that's it. In sport,
you're going to be learning
how to score points,
how to control a certain guy
with this specific uniform,
how to utilize that uniform.
How do you utilize the mat and that's
another thing that's messed up.
Like in the IB, Jj, after the
official rules of Jujitsu,
there's some things that
you're not allowed to do right.
And that's not good.
They should allow these things in
regards to pursuing self a sport.
It's a sport really when
it comes down to it. Yeah.
I guess you can put whatever rules you
want. Yeah, but you shouldn't. Yeah.
Yeah. If you, if you don't mind
the deviation from self defense,
if you don't mind that, then put
whatever rules you want. But yeah,
I would say you shouldn't. If you care
about the more rules you in the sport
gets, the less effective it
becomes. I unfortunately.
And so they need to stop with the rules.
Yeah. And it's the same thing with judo.
It's the same thing with wrestling.
I mean wrestling in America, if they,
if they allowed submission holds
in wrestling in America, you know,
America would be insane with fighters.
We've done pretty good.
But can you imagine if every high school
kid that wrestled knew how to do all
submissions? They'd be nuts. That's the
way it should be. I wish it was that way.
I wish the world was that way.
It would be a better place.
But they, what they did is, what they
did is with wrestling, they took,
they took submission holds out because
they considered it to be dangerous in
judo is a clock is a classic example
where they remove the double leg.
Like you can't do a straight
double leg in a tournament anymore.
You have to set it up.
It has to be off for something else.
Cause because wrestlers were coming in
and dominating and judo tournament just
hitting double legs cause cause
they're awesome at Adam. Right.
And it's the same thing now you see
with with Jujitsu in Ibj JF there,
you know with the,
with the no heel hooks,
even at a black belt level you're
not allowed to do, he'll hooks.
So that completely changed it.
Some parts of the Games and it doesn't
change and where it was going to make you
lose in a street fight.
But it definitely puts a stop to the,
to the growth of the sport
in terms of technique.
Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. So exactly
what you were saying, how the sport,
the rules and stuff, all that
does is, is narrowed down the,
the sport part of it and the more people
who pursue it for sport, not just sport,
but sport. If pursuing Jiu Jitsu for sport
is part of your game as part of your,
your goals or whatever,
and then now the sport has become
this limited thing where you can't,
like there's 20% of moves you can't do,
you're gonna spend way
less time practicing them.
You'd be way less effective at these
moves that are a part of grappling,
a huge part of grappling
ultimately. So. So yeah,
you're still going to have that huge
overlap for sure. If you know mount,
which is probably the first thing,
you would have your first Jujitsu class,
you're going to learn mount,
which is theoretically the most
dominant position you can have.
So you're going to learn mount, take
what to do when the guy flips you over,
what to do in the guard, how to
function. You know these things.
That's what's going to
get you by in the street.
That's what's going to going to make
you effective in an actual fight. Yeah.
And then, you know, like, like anything,
all these offshoots that grow, you know,
they, you know, there's some
overlap for sure. But, um, if,
if you go into a tournament
that's a specific pursuit.
If you want to defend yourself,
that's a specific pursuit now.
And as time goes on,
they're going to start to draw out that
there's a lot of overlap right now and
in the future there'll be less.
Yeah.
Has the way that they're putting rules
over the sport. Yeah. And, and just,
and the sport in general and
the sport mutating. Yeah.
Yeah. So you know, the sport,
depending on the,
depending on the fact that there's a mat,
like if you tried to do a burn Bolo in
the street with on the road or something,
it's just the way that
you spin on the mat. Yeah.
There's too much friction on the street.
It'd be definitely one that
would make it hard. Yes, you can.
The grass would make it hard.
Yeah.
I haven't tried to bear them Bolo on the
street. Go get a fight. Pick a fight.
Yeah, but both are good. I think it's fun.
You can't help but really
like, cause because when you
go to Jujitsu you're like,
hey, this is basically a fight. Yeah.
We can train full speed and be safe.
It's a fight. That's what makes
it so fun because when you win,
the payoff is so good on the
inside and when you lose,
it's like you still get that detriment.
That's still, you still have that feeling.
But at the end of the day, you know you
lived, you're not enemies with the guy,
you're not injured, nothing
like that. So it makes it this,
this wind when the whole time.
Right.
And when you see a cool move like warm
guard when like you're controlling one
guy with your weird foot that face this
way in one hand and the guy can't even
stand up. Yeah. That's
all fun. Yeah. It's like,
oh I have this super power and
wielding, you know, in the Mat.
He can't help it pursue those fun
thing. Bear and bull though. You get,
it's like you're a break
dancer doing some cool stuff.
Meanwhile you're dominating the guy.
While you're dead,
you can't help but do that stuff. It's so
fun, you know? Yeah. So you can't, I mean,
I don't think you can really
hate him. The sport. No, I don't.
I don't hate on a sport. Yeah, no, no, no,
no, no. I'm saying good, but some people,
do you know how even just the
question cut, not that the,
the person who asked this
question thinks this,
but it implies that there is a
little bit of a climate of, Oh yeah,
I got a receipt. If you don't like the
bear and Bolo, learn to defend against it.
No. Yeah. You know what I mean?
Sure. If you don't like Robert Gard,
cool learning to defend against
it. Yup. That's my opinion.
Because if it's working
then credit. Yup. Yup.
You either effective or ineffective.
My brother Leif Babin said,
yeah, let's do one more.
One more. Okay. Jocko,
a lot of your advice applies to leading
yourself, not just leading others.
Self-Help quote unquote is a loaded word.
So let's say self management.
What is the one change readers should
make today to start improving themselves
and their situation?
I don't really like those words.
Self help or self management
or self improvement.
I don't really like what those words
have come to mean these days because
there's a lot of people out there
that are constantly trying to improve
themselves by looking for the one change,
the one change,
right?
The one change in their life that's
gonna make their dreams come true
and even worse. On top of that,
there's a lot of people out there,
a lot of self help gurus
and these hyperactive
motivational speakers and these
other self appointed modern Zen Yoga
warriors that they're trying to sell.
The one thing they're trying to sell
the nine steps are the enlightened path
that's going to allow you to unlock all
of your human potential and fulfill the
dreams so you can live the life that
you've, you've always wanted to live.
Now I'm no guru,
Hey,
and I definitely don't claim to be,
I'm just a man.
But I will tell you this,
it isn't one thing and it isn't 10
things and it isn't a hundred things.
It isn't a quick path and
there are no shortcuts
in meditation,
won't get you there and neither will a
miracle drug or an organic supplement or
some super food.
Yeah.
Getting better isn't a hack or a trick
or a one change that you need to make.
Okay.
Getting better is a campaign.
It's a campaign.
It's a daily, a weekly.
It's an hour leaf fight.
Yeah.
An incessant fight that
doesn't stop against weakness
and against temptation and
against laziness. It's a
campaign. A discipline.
Okay.
The campaign of hard work and dedication.
It's waking up early and going to bed
late and grinding out every second in
between every single day.
So you want to get better.
Yeah.
You want to self improve.
Stop looking for a shortcut
and go find your alarm clock.
Find your discipline.
Yeah.
And flank your guts and your
passion and your drive and find it.
You will.
And then,
then you will find
your freedom.
And I think that's all
I've got for tonight. So
I'll you troopers out there,
out on the front lines,
fighting against evil or fighting against
crime or fighting against fires or
fighting to make things happen,
fighting.
They get ahead and make something out of
this little bit of time that we've got.
Thanks for joining us in the fight.
And if you want to keep
the conversation going,
you can find us on the interwebs at Jocko
Willink and echo is at Echo Charles.
Okay.
And if you want to support the podcast,
Echo's going to tell you
how there's a few ways,
easiest way, my opinion before
you do your Amazon shopping.
When you shop on amazon.com go to Jocko
podcast.com and then we have an Amazon
link there. You Click on there
and um, then you do shopping,
whether you buy a book or or whatever
or some batteries, some duck tape.
Also there is a Jocko store where you can
get shirts or coffee mugs or stickers.
You can support us by doing that
if you like the shirts. If not,
then obviously not. Um, and then, um,
if you want to take some supplements,
I recommend the good ones,
the ones that actually work,
and those are made by on it.
So if you go to on it.com/jocko,
you can get 10% off all supplements.
You can also support the podcast by
listening to it, by downloading it,
by subscribing to it, and by reviewing
it or wherever you listen to it.
Get on there and put a review on there.
Tell people what you think.
You can also get a book called extreme
ownership that was written by myself and
my brother Leif Babin.
And you can get it on digital hardcover.
You can get it on audio, which is
actually read by Leif Babin and myself.
And when you get done
supporting the podcast and
supporting the cause here,
go out there and do something
to support yourself,
to make yourself better.
Get out there into the world
and get after it.
And so until next time,
this is Jocko and echo
out.